a show of unity and support western
leaders announced new plans to punish
russia for its war in ukraine including
sanctions and more military aid for kiev
nato will also send additional battle
groups to eastern europe but will it be
enough to deter president vladimir putin
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fully batibo the war in ukraine has now
entered its second month the leaders of
nato the european union and the group of
seven nations have met in brussels
condemning russia's actions and
announcing more sanctions the 30 nato
allies said russia's invasion of ukraine
was the gravest threat to euro-atlantic
security in decades their aim was to
show solidarity to ukraine but only up
to a point many have been willing to
supply weapons but the alliance has also
made clear it won't become directly
involved u.s president joe biden also
committed more humanitarian assistance
to ukraine
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
we've built that same unity with our
european the european union and with the
leading democracies of the g7
while nato agreed more support for
ukraine it also announced it would
deploy additional battalions to protect
what it called its eastern border
so we are resetting nato's returns and
defense for the long term
with more troops
with more air assets and more maritime
capabilities
we have already increased our presence
in the east and today we decided on four
new battle groups and the leaders
agreed to task our military commanders
to provide options
for a long-term reset of our
presence our military posture in the
eastern part of the alliance and across
the whole alliance as the nato summit
got underway in brussels leaders heard a
call for more help from ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky who
addressed the gathering virtually
ukraine never wanted to fight we just
want to survive we are entitled to live
like other countries i am not blaming
nato it's not your missiles that are
ruining our country this morning
phosphorus bombs have been used and
adults and children have been killed the
alliance can still save our country by
giving us those weapons we never thought
nato can be afraid of russia i am sure
you understand russia will not stop in
ukraine and will go further against the
eastern members of nato the baltic
states and poland ukraine was just
asking for one percent of your tanks
either to give us or to sell them to us
but we haven't had any response this is
the worst that can happen during a war
well let's take a look at what the west
has done so far to support ukraine the
u.s and its allies have delivered
weapons and financial aid to ukraine
including anti-aircraft systems
anti-armor systems and drones they've
also shared intelligence they've imposed
sweeping economic sanctions against
russia and the u.s has announced
additional measures against more than
400 individuals and entities billions of
dollars worth of humanitarian aid have
also been flowing in to assist people
inside ukraine washington says they'll
provide one billion dollars more in
humanitarian assistance but president
zielinski's repeated requests for a
no-fly zone over ukraine have pretty
much been ignored
[Music]
well let's now bring in our guests for
today's inside story from odessa in
ukraine we are joined by hannah chaletz
she is the director of security programs
with ukrainian prison that's a ukrainian
foreign policy and security think tank
vladimir sotnikov joins us from moscow
he is the director of the consultancy
russia east-west center for strategic
studies and analysis and from washington
d.c we're joined by nigel gold davis
he's a senior fellow for russia and
eurasia with the international institute
for strategic studies and a former uk
ambassador to belarus welcome to you all
thank you very much for being with us on
inside story mr sotnikov in moscow let
me start with you if i can western
leaders have been touting unity in their
response to russia announcing new
military aid to ukraine and new
sanctions against moscow will this be
enough to deter president vladimir putin
well actually i think that uh the
results of this uh three uh very
important for western leaders meetings
and
in
brussels uh
according to the opinion of western
leaders showed the unusual unity against
against russia but
uh
my point is that um even the growing up
of
all the
rapid rapid increase increasing of
the um
native forces in uh on the borders of uh
on the western borders with with russia
and
near side ukraine
and the
very much harsh
economic sanctions will only speed up
the uh hard wheel of
russian president vladimir putin and he
already announced a very unexpected
solution to pay in rubles for
uh the gas supplies in uh to european
countries to actually to european
community countries european union
countries so i think that uh
eventually i think that at the end of
the day
it might be looking like like a loose
position then
alternatively that they win position
because actually russia will find
uh at my um opinion uh some are some
asymmetric measures like uh suggesting
paying rubles
interesting anna chaletz your thoughts
are ukrainian leaders how are they
viewing this uh
additional support from the west does it
go far enough
first of all i would like to clarify
that sounds really odd when we are
seeing that additional battlegroup that
nato is going to settle in slovakia or
in romania is just on the russian
borders considering is that it is at
least 105 kilometers from romania to the
nearest russian territory so that is
definitely the huge exaggeration of that
something what will diver putin
manipulated a lot in his uh speeches but
at the same time we are speaking about
how ukraine reacted to the yesterday
decisions first of all for us definitely
being important that the unity continued
within the countries both in the
european union and nato we understand
that nato first of all is trying to
protect their territory that's why the
battle groups are first of all to
protect and to defend the nato member
states but still it was very nice to
hear in the statements at the joint
statement and the individual statements
uh both the uh not only what nato cannot
do but what nato is doing and what nato
can do for ukraine including uh talks
about additional ammunition for uh
anti-tank and anti-missile uh that is
additional support in terms of cyber
security biological security and
chemical weapons security that is the
new threats that are now sounding uh
from moscow and that is definitely uh
additional commitments in terms of the
security and humanitarian aid for
ukraine we understand that the biggest
part of the agreements were not public
and they were not uh announced and that
is really important because that is very
sensitive information and if we would
like to be safe we would not tell that
five new tanks would cross the polish
border for example because they are
immediately becoming detergent indeed we
did not hear the details about what
additional weapons were going to be
supplied mr nigel gould davis in
washington dc western leaders are
clearly
faced with a delicate balance between
influencing the course of the conflict
in ukraine and avoiding dangerous
escalation beyond it
the show of western unity that we saw in
brussels on thursday a very strong
symbol no doubt but how practical is it
in terms of security both defense and
energy security
yes and you're right to mention the
energy dimension as well because let's
remember
that the the meetings that have taken
place this week are not only of nato but
the eu and the g7 ii and this indeed is
a i would say unprecedented display of
collective uh western unity uh and uh i
mean put this into context this is
really the third time since the second
world war that we've seen uh russian or
during the cold war that was soviet uh
overreaching a threat to europe invoking
a collective western response the first
time the late 1940s the second was early
1970s and the third and most emphatic is
today
um but yes of course there are dilemmas
uh always and balances to be struck in
the way that this is done
uh and
i think it's important for the west now
this is a one of the main purposes of
these meetings to demonstrate continued
resolve and that western unity won't uh
diminish or weaken and i know there are
expectations or hope on the russian side
that the western position was gradually
softened as it has in the past and that
is really the question is it
how hard will it be to maintain this
unity if the the conflicts becomes more
brutal we're already starting to see
some cracks within the european union
with countries that want more sanctions
imposed against russia and those like
germany who thinks that the sanctions
have gone far enough how long and uh and
uh you know how long can they maintain
this unity
yes well it's uh uh the next sanctions
measures that could be taken uh
particularly against russian energy are
the harder ones and the more costly ones
and i think that uh the west is doing
the right things and preparing the
ground for that so one of the most
interesting uh announcements uh
yesterday was that germany would uh in
effect wean itself off dependence on
russian gas by 2024 it's painful and
difficult to do but they are preparing
the way for a post-russian energy future
uh and uh
already we've seen and and this and on
other uh uh aspects of this whole issue
uh germany moving in ways that no one
really predicted i would say it's less a
matter of cracks at this moment and more
a matter of the unequal speed of
progress but again overall i think it's
been a very uh impressive um display of
unity and uh continues what i think has
been a highly effective diplomatic
campaign going really back to last
october on the part of the united states
mr sotnikov your thoughts about this is
the war weakening president putin's
position in russia as the west's hope
cities first of all i would like uh to
actually um take in into notice the
remark by another side i didn't mean
actually the
the russian borders
just right near the western countries
like poland uh actually
anyway ultimately this is the western
western western borders of russia it's
not like that russia actually is in
ukrainian territory uh and
it is claiming that this is a russian
territory it's not like that uh secondly
i would like um to
have my
remark on the nigel's uh
nigel's remarks actually i think that uh
uh in terms of energy
it's a rather difficult uh uh
immediately or just even by the year
after
2024
to
to substitute the russian supplies
because it seems to me that even uh
ursula den leiden de leyden actually
said that there will be an organized
central central system of concluding the
contracts
uh it's rather rigid system actually uh
which is functioning already and it's
difficult to understand how it will be
function in the future and how
successful will the attempts
to um have the adequate volume supplies
from qatar nowhere from any other
country which would like to supply the
lng
as we got sorry can you repeat your
question actually again my question was
about whether the war uh in ukraine was
weakening president putin's position in
russia because ultimately this is what
the west is looking for
okay probably i might
as well disappoint you but
it's very unusual that the support of a
russian president's action
in russia in russia it's more than 70 so
you cannot imagine it because nobody
actually imagined these figures when a
month ago this special operation started
so i don't think that this special
operation even the economic hardships
which are looming uh not existing but
looming
in the prospective time will allusion to
my mind
uh or rapidly or not rapidly will losing
the position or will weakening the
position of president truth hannah your
response to that your thoughts about
what uh vladimir just said that he
thinks uh he says that president putin's
position within russia is only actually
getting stronger as a result of this
operation
yes definitely we also have decent
permission and it can be easily uh
supported not only by the sociological
surveys but the actual situation how
many of the russians supported the war
against ukraine and plenty of the
international journal has been trying to
get interviews on the streets and
different cities around russia asking
about uh these war and russian
aggression and we really been shocked by
the positive attitude people didn't feel
anything negative about bombing of
archival marijuana and and that's really
scared us because previously in the west
talking with a lot of diplomats i heard
for many years that okay let's just wait
mr putin would step down or retire and
situation would change in the russian
federation we also wanted to be the same
optimistic but now seeing the strong
support of the military actions not just
of the policy inside of the country it's
really shocking and there is no the same
hope that just the retirement of russian
president can actually change the
attitude of the russian federation
against all other uh neighbors of this
country well let's take a closer look
now at the situation on the ground a
month on from the russian invasion of
ukraine the areas in red are held by
russian forces and their separatist
allies their military advance has
largely sold ukrainian forces in
besieged mario paul are holding out and
ukraine says it successfully pushed back
russian advances with counter-offensives
on the outskirts of the capital kiev
nigel what is your sense of where the
conflict stands and where it's headed
and how long can ukraine hold out with
this additional support that's been
provided by by nato and other western
countries
very little about this war has gone in
the way that russia hoped or intended
and it's faced a series of setbacks uh
that have exposed uh weaknesses in its
uh
uh it's its political assumptions about
the the situation in ukraine and about
the performance the logistics the
communications and the tactics of russia
military forces themselves
uh that said russia still has a very
large number of forces it could continue
to commit uh to this but it knows russia
knows that as the flow of western uh
support comes into ukraine it will
become harder rather than easier
still for russia and all the reports
that we have about the morale and the
motivation on the two sides in the field
suggests that ukraine's uh forces are
far more disciplined and far more
motivated in this fight so things are
looking very difficult for russia which
is precisely why there is the fear in
the west of a potential escalation
and it's really escalation scenarios of
the greatest worry here and we've heard
in the last few days serious incredible
worries
from uh western sources that russia
might be contemplating the use of
chemical uh or even more dangerous
weapons and there are steps being taken
to protect nato uh against that right um
the other aspect just to go back to an
earlier part of the discussion the
economic costs that russia is facing on
the home front so it's facing military
costs in the field economic costs at
home and these sanctions um they are
only just beginning to do their work uh
the russian economy in every respect
faces
unprecedented and rapid difficulties in
coming months let's see what happens to
russian public opinion as those
consequences work themselves out in
russia and not just the effect on
russian public opinion but in elites as
well why watch russian television and
watch these curated uh sort of footage
of uh of russian elites i see lots of
lots of unhappy and worried faces and i
think those around putin are privately
very alarmed and very unhappy about the
consequences of this war vladimir in
moscow is the war going the way russia
wants does russia see this war as being
a winnable one
well what i would like to say in this
regard that probably i i'm not a
military expert i am not connected with
um general chief of staff i i can only
assume i assume that first of first at
first the
operation the special operation could be
regarded as the
as the uh strike which is uh lightning
strike but
then probably the
strategy which russian military uh
planners have in their mind
had changed because it's something it's
understandable that uh uh
uh when the actual war is uh
is waged on the ground so that means
that uh there will be victims on both
sides the ukrainian side and the russian
side
and another part of this strategy
probably is uh to avoid unnecessary uh
civic casualties solar russia actually
is
to my mind is trying to do this at least
so i think
grounds to show differently
unfortunately as far as civilian
casualties
i don't know actually i can't i cannot
say definitely because unfortunately i
cannot see a lot of videos you know we
have blocked uh
youtube and other other western uh
western uh
gadgets i mean but i i i can only assume
that this strategy is working that uh
to avoid uh as much
civilian casualties as russia can do
in terms of military strategy
sorry to interrupt you
yes hannah if you want to jump in go
ahead
i i really wanted to jump i understand
that youtube is blocked but i will be
glad to send through the messages uh
some videos and the problem is exactly
uh the opposite that the original
operation being uh definitely as
vladimir said the lighting the idea of
the lighting but when it uh haven't
happened like this the next level was
the landing operation tried to capture
the city of kiev it also didn't work uh
well because of the last eight years
ukrainian armed forces been preparing
training and modernizing so they were
ready to fight but then when this losses
started from the russian side what being
chosen it is the use of the heavy
weapons first of all missiles and
bombardment of the cities of the
civilian object and we can see it not
only uh about marijuana these uh awful
videos and the tragedies of what is
happening there are now all around the
international media are just the rest
and boom
of the uh dramatic theater where 300
people been hiding and it's been
airborned all people died yeah but also
let's look to the city of kharkiv that
is completely destroyed okay let's look
to the
hospitals uh 300 schools and all are the
civilian objects around the country
indeed i just want to ask you
just to move the conversation forward a
little bit because we are aware of the
the different uh reports on the ground
in in ukraine uh as nigel said there are
fears of what steps russia might take
next to unblock this campaign
and perhaps force ukraine to make
concessions at the negotiating table
because the two sides are talking
what is ukraine prepared to concede
would ukraine be willing to cede any
territory for example in order to gain a
ceasefire with moscow
now as for now if we speak about the
territory that russians tried to control
after 24th of february unfortunately i
don't see the screen what map you've
been showing but i can assume that is
the same map that i saw in other of your
shows uh
so that is not the whole territory red
territory that the russian federation is
controlling they are controlling
predominantly the roads around there uh
from regional centers only one here soon
being occupied as for now that is on the
south near crimea in other territories
the russians are bombing but they are
not controlling completely and they
didn't occupy the cities themselves so
that's why as for now ukraine cannot
surrender or capitulate or give some of
the territories because they are still
not controlled by the russian federation
okay
as we see in some of the places like
from nikolai we're even moving them uh
further still it is the issue with the
nets glue guns and crimea the
territories have been occupied by the
russian federation earlier okay due to
the 2014 events and here i understand
that one of the compromises can be to
return back to the negotiations prayer
february 2022 when we've been just
discussing the future of the netga and
lugansk cities okay vladimir would
russia consider some of these
concessions what would it take for
russia to stop this war today
let me just uh direct our
discussion in some other direction i
mean that uh regarding distance sessions
i think that at the end of the day both
sides who are worrying with each other
uh
whatever you name it
uh could be that both sides should give
should
give concessions and should
uh productively walk towards the peace
peaceful settlement so i think that this
situation which you are asking before
the 24th of uh
february is not realistic for the moment
because
the situation is completely different so
i mean that uh probably this is my uh
assumption probably to reach a peaceful
peaceful settlement okay ukraine should
negotiate
the uh giving uh the independence so
just to recognize the uh
donetsk and lugansk and crimea is a part
of russia and russia should continue on
these
conditions
nigel you have the last word what
choices does russia face now
uh putin is all in on this war he's
committed a great deal of military and
political capital to it the only thing
that will stop him continuing it is if
he reaches a conclusion that it's more
risky to carry on the war than it is to
stop it he is unfortunately far from
that situation right now despite the
costs that he has incurred on the
battlefield and that sanctions will
impose on him at home and that's why the
west has uh displayed this uh
unprecedented degree
of unity uh the final point i'd make is
i'm sorry there's absolutely no doubt
whatsoever that russia is deliberately
targeting civilians in large numbers now
uh they are no longer confident they can
defeat ukrainian forces they are trying
to
coerce ukraine into making concessions
by hurting large and killing large
numbers of innocent people this is siege
warfare in the 21st century we'll leave
it there thank you very much for a very
dynamic conversation thank you hannah
chaletz uh vladimir sutnikov and nigel
gold davis thank you and thank you for
watching you can always watch this
program again anytime by visiting our
website at aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's
slash aj inside story you can of course
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
fully [ __ ] the whole team here in
doha thanks for watching bye for now
you